hey everyone it's sarah red sterner
sorry and calm and today we're going to
talk about Luke diuretics
and as always when you get done watching
this YouTube video you can access the
free quiz that will test you on this
medication so let's get started
as we've been going through this
pharmacology series we have been
remembering the word nurse which helps
us determine those important concepts
that we need to know about these drugs
that we are studying and again in stands
for name because this tells us how the
drug works on the body what family of
drugs is a part of you tells us what it
is used for what is it tree are tells us
the responsibilities of the nurse and
this is where a lot of test questions
will come from to determine if you know
how to care for a patient who is taking
this drug S stands for side effects and
then e stands for the education pieces
for the patient about this medication so
let's start with a name we are dealing
with loop diuretics loop tells us that
this medication is going to influence
how the loop of Henle works within this
nephron and specifically loop diuretics
effect the thick ascending limb of the
loop of Henle diuretics tells us that
this medication is going to somehow
increase the urinary output by affecting
how sodium is reabsorbed back into the
blood it's actually going to inhibit
that process from occurring so you have
more sodium within this nephron and if
you have more sodium you're going to
keep water within that nephron instead
of it going back into the blood so these
medications can help remove extra fluid
volume from a patient who's like in
fluid volume overload now loop diuretics
are the most powerful of all the
diuretics and will be also talking about
thiazide x' and potassium sparing
diuretics and our next videos and to
help you recognize if you're dealing
with a loop diuretic or a thiazide or a
potassium sparing diuretic always look
at the end of the generic name loop
diuretics tend in
ni de or my m ID and some examples are
like you met an AI furosemide and tore
some ID with exception of ethic rinic
acid which doesn't end in night or mine
so what loop diuretics do again is they
effect this thick ascending limb of the
loop of Henle and particularly what it's
going to do is it's going to inhibit a
special protein coat transporter from
doing its job and this cotransporter is
the sodium potassium chloride
transporter and what it does just like
its name says it does is it's going to
help transport some specific ions from
the filtrate to go back into the
interstitium into the blood and those
ions will be one sodium one potassium
and two chloride and then we'll take
that from the filtrate and in a sense
push it back to go back into the
interstitium which will go into the
blood however if we inhibit this ion
transport specifically the transport of
sodium we're going to alter some things
because it's going to change the tone
isset II of this medulla inner stitch
them because this area is very hyper
tonic so if we decrease its tone isset
II it's going to alter how specific
parts of this nephron are able to
reabsorb water back into the body
instead more water will stay in this
filtrate and hence will be urinated out
which hits our goal of increasing
urinary output however to truly
understand this whole process we've got
to go back and we have to review the
anatomy and physiology of this nephron
here on the right we have an
illustration of a nephron and if we took
one and we stretched it out it would
look something similar to this and how
its structures are set up and here on
the Left we have how that nephron
actually sets within the kidney and you
want to take note of this because some
parts of the nephron are found in the
cortex which is like an isotonic
environment compared to some of them
being
found in the medulla which is a
hypertonic environment and this helps
you understand how these nephrons work
with the way that they will tweak the
water and the ions so these nephrons are
structures within the kidneys that allow
them to function and without them
actually working properly the kidneys
won't be able to do their job and there
are millions of these nephron units in
each kidney and they function to manage
the water ions and waste that will be
reabsorbed by the body or excreted as
urine and the nephron can be divided
into several parts each part of the
nephron has its own unique role for
tweaking the filtrate that is created by
the glomerulus until it's just what the
body needs and what it doesn't need it
will be excreted as urine and these
parts include the afferent arteriole and
the efferent arteriole and the afferent
arteriole is going to take blood via the
renal artery and deliver it to the
nephron so it can be filtered and the
every arteriole will take that blood
that's been filtered and send it back to
the body so blood enters into the
nephron via the afferent arteriole and
it's going to be filtered by the
glomerulus
and the glomerulus will create the
filtrate which will eventually exit the
body as urine and in this filtrate or
ions which are like electrolytes like
potassium sodium magnesium etc water and
waste and this will drip down into
Bowman's capsule now it's going to
encounter its first to be aware the
tweaking of what will be needed by the
body or excreted by the body via the
urine is going to occur so it goes
through the proximal convoluted tubule
and remember that this area so far is
setting in that renal cortex which is an
isotonic environment then that filtrate
is going to go down into the descending
loop of Henle so this is like that first
structure of the loop of Henle and this
is found in the medulla and again it's
hypertonic so it's very salty compared
to the isotonic and
in the cortex where the salt content was
equal on the inside of the nephron
compared to the outside but here in the
medulla that is different so really
salty on the outside which is going to
play a role in the way that water is
reabsorbed
so the filtrate goes down this ascending
lute limb of the loop of Henle and what
I want you to remember about this
descending limb is that it is permeable
to water but it's not permeable to ions
which means water can leave this land
that ions cannot so because it's so
salty here hypertonic water is going to
leave this descending limb which is
going to concentrate that filtrate and
make it really concentrated with sodium
and all those other ions then the
filtrate is going to go up through the
ascending limb of the loop of Henle and
it's going to hit the thick ascending
limb and this is where loop diuretics
work remember they block that
co-transporter the sodium potassium
chloride co-transporter and I thought
filtrate hits this thick ascending limb
it's really concentrated so normally
those ions are going to be transported
specifically that sodium that'll help
keep that renal medulla hypertonic
however whenever we're throwing in a
loop diuretic that's not gonna work very
well so then the filtrate will go up
through the distal convoluted tubule it
has left that hypertonic environment now
it's back in the cortex where it's
isotonic again it's going to be tweaked
depending on what the body needs and
then the filtrate is gonna go down
through the collecting duct and some of
this area enters again into the medulla
where you're gonna have some more water
reabsorption by the body and then the
filtrate will go through the renal
pelvis and then eventually will be
urinated out so we've just seen how
filtrate is created by this nephron and
how it flows through the nephron and
event
exits the body as urine however since
we're talking about loop diuretics we
have to dive a little bit deeper into
this loop of Henle and how loop
diuretics affect the loop of Henle to
cause diuresis to increase urinary
output and one thing it's going to do
it's going to affect how the body is
going to reabsorb sodium so keep that in
mind because if we're not reabsorbing
sodium it's staying in the nephron that
means water is gonna stay in there and
it's going to exit the body hence
increasing our urination so we said that
in the proximal convoluted tubule the
filtrate is there it's in that nice
isotonic environment but then once it
goes down into the loop of Henle it's
gonna go into the medulla which is
hypertonic it's really salty and there's
two parts of that loop of Henle we have
the descending limb in the ACE ending
limb and they're really different and
what they're permeable to what they
allow to leave the nephron and go back
into the interstitium and into the blood
so filtrate comes down from the proximal
convoluted tubule hits this descending
limb of the loop of Henle and remember
that was permeable only to water not
ions and since its hit this really salty
environment the waters like hey we're
leaving we like salt so the water leaves
the filtrate and this loop of Henle is
actually responsible for about 15 to 20
percent of water reabsorption so it
reabsorbs a lot of water so now waters
left and the filtrate is really
concentrated with these ions which is
great because once it hits this
ascending limb the ascending limb deals
with that because remember this thick
part of this sending limb is permeable
to ions those electrolytes but not water
so hits this ending limb and you have
all these little Co transporters
simipour channels that are going to help
allow ions to leave this filtrate go
through the cell hit the inter stitch
and go to the blood and they're all
working together beautiful
to do their job and one of those code
transporters was the sodium potassium
chloride co-transporter so it takes one
sodium one potassium two chloride takes
it puts it back into the blood now the
cool thing about the loop of Henle it's
responsible for about 25 percent of the
sodium reabsorption which it's gonna
play a role in keeping this renal
medulla hypertonic keeps it salty so we
can play a role with reabsorbing water
because also you're collecting doug's
once it hits this hypertonic environment
water is going to be removed right
before it leaves so if we throw in
something like a loop diuretic that's
going to inhibit this co-transporter
from transporting especially the sodium
the potassium and chloride we're going
to alter the tone isset ii of this
environment which is going to decrease
how much water is able to be reabsorbed
through the collecting duct and from
this loop of Henle so if the water is
not leaving this nephron it's staying in
there because we have lots of sodium
still in here and remember sodium water
love each other the water is going to
stay in this nephron it's not going to
be reabsorbed through the body so it's
gonna leave the body as urine and we've
hit our goal we have increased urinary
output now let's talk about what loop
diuretics are used for what do they
treat well we've already established
with how luke diuretics effect this
nephron is that they're gonna increase a
patient's ability to urinate so they're
gonna be putting out a lot more urine
well if you're putting out a lot more
urine that's dropping your fluid volume
in your blood now why would we want to
draw up a patient's fluid volume well
patients who are in fluid volume
overload where they have way too much
fluid hanging out in the blood and this
can occur in patients who have heart
failure where the heart is just so weak
it just can't pump blood forward and you
have different types like systolic
dysfunction or diastolic dysfunction but
the blood can backflow go into the lungs
leading to pulmonary edema
literally it's like the patient is
drowning in their own fluid and the
fluid can leak and go into the lower
extremities where you have swelling
there as edema so we throw on this loop
diuretic that is going to tell the blood
once it's being filtered by this nephron
hey we're not going to be sending too
much water back to you because we're
going to tell this nephron not to
reabsorb this water because we're going
to alter the sodium content in our
nephron and around in this medulla we're
not gonna make it as hypertonic so guess
what you're not gonna have some fluid
coming back to the body instead this
patients going to urinate it out also
patients who have liver impairment where
they get the side effect of ascites
where they have a lot of swelling in the
abdomen that can help with that patient
the pulmonary edema as we just talked
about and hypertension leave diuretics
aren't as helpful with hypertension
compared to like thiazide but sometimes
they're prescribed for that to help
lower the blood pressure and that would
come from lowering the fluid volume
which will lower the pressure same
concept you lower the amount of water
that's going through a water hose you're
gonna lower the pressure and it also
treats hypercalcemia which is where you
have a high calcium level in the blood
but how can loop diuretics treat a high
calcium level in the blood well we've
learned that loop diuretics really
manipulate how ions are going to be
transported back into the blood from
this filtrate because we're inhibiting
this sodium potassium chloride
transporter and that will throw things
off so normally the filtrate will flow
down through here remember once it
passes this distal limb it's going to be
really concentrated in ions so we're not
only talking about like sodium potassium
chloride we're also talking about
calcium and magnesium they're positively
charged so they're going to go up in
this thick ascending limb where we're
having normally if we don't have a loop
diuretic we will have sodium one sodium
one potassium and two chloride being
transported over also working as well
doing its ion exchanges like the sodium
potassium pump you can have potassium
chloride symporters
and calcium channels and all of this
together is creating this like positive
potential this concentrate electrical
gradient that can normally take this
calcium and this magnesium and force it
out of this filtrate to go back into the
interstitium
and be reabsorbed into the blood but if
we inhibit this co-transporter that's
going to throw those things off and
we'll lose that positive potential so
the calcium and the magnesium will stay
in the filtrate will not go and be
reabsorbed and that can lower our
calcium levels and our magnesium levels
more so our calcium levels so that's why
we can use this to treat high calcium
levels and I'll talk about the
responsibilities of the nurse and the
side effects associated with Luke
diuretics we're going to mesh the two so
with patients taking loop diuretics
thread a huge risk for dehydration so we
want to monitor their fluid status and
make sure they're not becoming
dehydrated how can we do that well we
can look at their vital signs and see
where's their blood pressure is that
systolic less than 90 we've probably
diurese them a little bit too much how's
their heart rate are they tachycardic
where it's above a hundred that can be
signs of dehydration
along with excessive thirst being
lethargic and we want to make sure we
are strictly measuring their intake and
output because we don't want the patient
just consuming all this fluid and it's
really undermining the effectiveness of
this drug or we don't want them to be
just putting out so much where they have
this major negative loss of fluid
compared to how much they've been taking
in so for me and you want to make sure
that you give them a urinal and you
measure it every time you into that
urinal and women that you put the tool
that height in the toilet so you can
collect the urine and if they have the
Foley you can just look and see how much
urine was put out of the Foley plus we
want to make sure that they're putting
out enough here and and that we're not
sending them into like renal failure and
we're going to be collecting the
weights daily at the same time using the
same scale and we're looking and seeing
how much their weight is fluctuating
because Wayne a patient is a great
indicator of their fluid volume status
and how much weight they're losing
because if they're gaining 3 pounds in
like a 24-hour period that's not good
that means they're retaining too much
fluid so we will look at that and
compare that and we want to monitor
their labs patients who are going to be
on live directs especially there's IV
forms they're gonna be getting daily
basic metabolic panels where we can look
at their electrolytes and the renal
status so one thing you're really going
to look at is the potassium if you can't
remember anything else about live
diuretics remember that loop diuretics
can lower the potassium level it can
cause hypokalemia a normal potassium
level is 3 point 5 to 5 milli
equivalents per liter and it's very
common if your patients on long term
loop diuretics or those IV routes
they're going to be receiving some type
of potassium supplementation to help
replace that potassium level and I want
to point out this with digoxin this is
the big thing you need to know we cover
this in the digoxin video that we went
over in this pharmacology series but if
your patient is on digoxin and they're
taking a loop diuretic you always always
want to look at that potassium level
before you minister their next dose of
digoxin because it can increase digoxin
toxicity so they're on digoxin taking a
loop what are you gonna look at there
potassium level we don't want them to
have hypokalemia now why can they have a
low potassium level well what's
happening is that remember we're not
having these ions being transported
across so they're going back into the
blood so one ion that's really gonna be
concentrated in this filtrate will be
sodium so once the filtrate goes up it's
gonna hit the distal convoluted tubule
and in this tube you'll especially the
distal part it uses a
transporter that is influenced by
aldosterone to reabsorb sodium and one
thing that we have learned about
aldosterone in our lectures is that it
will cause the body to keep sodium but
excrete potassium so we have a high
amount of sodium here it's influenced by
this aldosterone so it's really going to
enhance how the aldosterone is gonna
work so you'll be keeping reabsorbing
the sodium but you're going to be
excreting potassium now only are you
going to excrete potassium which is
going to lower the level you're going to
excrete hydrogen ions so the patient can
also have metabolic alkalosis as well
with these loop diuretics so that is
another side effect so it can also draw
up your magnesium level which we talked
about over here with how it's affecting
how calcium magnesium are being
reabsorbed and of course it can drop
your sodium level because we're keeping
sodium in the snare on and excreting it
out another thing that I want you to
remember is that loop diuretics can
increase uric acid levels so watch out
for signs and symptoms of gout and why
is it increasing uric acid levels
well the proximal convoluted tubule is
being affected with how is dealing with
urea and urate is a waste and what this
medication can do unfortunately is cause
the body to increase its absorption of
urate which in turn will increase uric
acid levels so that's another thing you
have to watch out for and another thing
I want you to remember is that loop
diuretics can cause inner ear damage
with a condition called odo toxicity and
as a nurse how can you prevent this from
happening
one way is slowly and ministry IV routes
of loop diuretics so when a patient is
ordered like IV lasix or all some I'd
you want to give it slowly because we
don't want to cause inner ear damage and
as a nurse you're going to be looking at
the effectiveness of this drug you're
going to be looking at their weights are
they
losing weight meaning they're losing
fluid you're gonna see how much urine
they're putting out look at their eyes
and O's you're gonna listen to their
lungs do they sound clear or you hear
crackles where there's still fluid in
there and look at their edema they're
swelling has their legs swelling went
down they they're not pitting as much
and even the patient's starting to feel
better a lot of patients will report wow
I feel so much better since I've had
this fluid removed and one thing you
want to keep in mind as the nurse is
when to give this loop diuretic because
as I pointed out they're very powerful
and they work pretty fast so if you if
the dose is order dry before bedtime
that's probably not the best time to
give it to the patient because they're
gonna be up throughout the night
urinating which is going to affect their
sleep and if they're trying to get to
the bathroom in the dark that can
increase the risk of falling Plus let's
say a dose is due but they have to go
for a procedure you want to make sure
that you call that department and make
sure that patient is going to have
access to the bathroom because they will
have to urinate after taking this
medication now let's wrap up this
lecture and let's talk about the
education pieces for the patient so we
definitely want to teach them to watch
out for signs and symptoms of
dehydration because they're going to be
urinating a lot we don't want to deplete
their fluid volume so you want to teach
them to watch out for excessive thirst
where they're not urinating at all or
they're really tired and to monitor
their blood pressure and heart rate at
home if there are really hypotensive
where that systolic is less than 90 and
all that together they'll want to report
to their physician and teaching them
about following a healthy diet and
eating foods that are rich in potassium
because we're wasting potassium and
foods that are rich from potassium are
like potatoes avocados bananas spinach
etc so they definitely don't want to
restrict that and they want to change
positions slowly when they're getting up
from a sitting or lying down position
because we're changing the fluid volume
status in the patient they can have
orthostatic hypotension and we don't
want
to get up and fall so encourage that and
to weigh themselves daily and to record
it because as a nurse that's performer
nursing interventions we are weighing
them we want to see their fluid status
so they need to do that as well and to
monitor their weights and make sure that
they're not gaining like no more than 3
pounds per day because that could be a
sign that they're retaining fluid okay
so that wraps up this review over loop
diuretics thank you so much for watching
don't forget to take the free quiz and
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos